story in the new york post that i had to
bring up on the show today
classic new york post type headline
supposed to be a pretty wacky story here
my husband is gay
but we're married with two kids and have
great sex
the woman for a beautiful woman the guy
good-looking guy the good-looking guy
apparently is not particularly attracted
to the good-looking woman but they're
married anyway and they have kids and
they
do the thing that married couples do
wow how kooky and crazy isn't it
this is an amazing story
it's amazing that this story is
considered so unusual
the they're mormons or at least the man
is mormon
uh the mormon church says no you can't
do gay marriage or gay relationships and
if you have same-sex attraction you just
basically have to
repress it and
be celibate or chaste or but you can't
you can't engage in that and this guy
has decided to prioritize his religion
and his culture and his upbringing over
his sexual desires he's not deceiving
anybody that he's told this woman on
their first date that hey i'm a gay guy
i'm really basically just attracted to
to men
and she said oh okay and rather than
just
running away from him she said actually
it's kind of
it doesn't really bother me that
physical attraction is not the most
important thing in our relationship
actually she says she realized that he
was her guy that they were really and he
said that about her and they were really
meant to be together
and they broke up for a little bit when
he was trying to work through his sexual
desires
and then they got back together because
they missed each other
so it just wasn't a huge deal
he has with me his choice
what else mattered
now they're happy and they got these
kids and okay
first of all
this is what gay guys did for like all
of human history
okay not not all okay some people would
be celibate or you know they'd be
confirmed bachelors or you know they'd
live with a very good friend of theirs
for a long time
but this was pretty common if you had
same-sex attractions you would just
repress it
as if you had any other
desire that you didn't want to
live out or engage in for for whatever
reason religion culture tradition
now we're told that that's evil that
that's wrong if you have any desire you
have especially any sexual desire you
have to fulfill it
but my question for the sexual
revolutionaries who say that you
absolutely have to you know it's your
choice you have any choice you can
choose to be with
a man you can choose to be with a woman
you can choose to be with two men and a
goat you can choose whatever you want
and that's wonderful and we need to
celebrate all of that well why don't we
celebrate his choice
why
why is his choice not valid
he is he's being completely honest about
everything and he's just saying look i
would rather have the life
that comes with
being married to a woman
with kids
in my church community in my culture i
would i would rather make that choice
even if my
kind of instinctual desire
is look this is a this is a crazy world
it's a very diverse world
there's no end to the uh diversity and
eccentricity of human beings but he says
in my rational will and my conscious
will i'm just going to choose
to repress that that sort of desire and
i'm going to marry this woman and by by
the way he
he's being so clear here because
he's not saying that he's going to pray
away the gay as some people kind of
derisively call it he's not saying he's
ever going to completely eradicate this
desire from himself but it is simply a
case of desire
the case with desire rather that
habit helps to form our desires
so it's not like our desires are just
permanently fixed
right when we're little kids
we like milk chocolate we just love milk
chocolate we can't c.s lewis makes this
point you can't imagine that there's
anything better than milk chocolate but
as you grow you still like chocolate but
your desires can change your tastes can
develop you can develop a taste for
coffee you can develop a taste for
scotch
you can do when i was little my favor i
would love to play cowboys and indians
to get back to a point where we're
making earlier
now i love to sit outside with a book
and a cigar when i was a little kid i
didn't want to sit outside with a book
or a cigar
not until i was 15 and i was a grown-up
boy now i don't like playing cowboys and
indians our desires actually change as
well and we can cultivate desires and
the more we practice certain habits
not that you're ever going to completely
get rid of some desire perhaps
but why do you not have that choice it
does show the intolerance the bigotry
the shallowness
of the left
and the the modern revolutionary view of
sex and identity and desire
that this that the only thing that
you're not allowed to do
is
choose the more traditional
path that's the only thing you're not
allowed to do anymore
i'm so glad you like that clip
i'm really it makes me feel very good
now if you want to get more clips like
that you've got to
ring the bell subscribe you'll get full
episodes of the show and if you want the
fully uncensored show and maybe you get
more notifications than our big tech
friends want to allow head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play
type in the michael knowles show th e
space m-i-c-h-a-e-l-space
k-n-w-l-e-s space s-h-o-w
period
subscribe to the michael noel show leave
a five-star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]